Make sure you guys hit the subscribe button.
If you guys are enjoying the content that we're throwing up and make sure you
guys hit the like button, if you enjoyed the video and yeah, let's begin.
What's going on guys. This is.
Brought and a couple of things before we start this video.
Um, for those of you guys who were on the discord server.
And you'll find a link to the discord down in the description, uh,
we have some cool stuff coming for you guys, right?
So we've got like a Whittler bot where like a,
the Riddler will like escape from Arkema slalom and we'll show up at different
places throughout the server. And if you guess is riddle correctly,
then one of the winners will be picked for something like a t-shirt maybe a Rob
core ring or something like that. We're still getting the rewards,
rewards fleshed out, but that'll be coming relatively soon.
And then we're also kicking around the idea of a Dungeons and dragons or
superhero themed done as a dry, dry DMD kind of tournament,
which seems like it'd be really cool.
A lot of you guys have been asking me for it for a while. So, uh,
make sure you guys check out the discourse server down in the description.
I think it'd be pretty awesome, but, um,
but what I want to talk about in this video is I want to talk about Thor for
specifically like Gore the Godbold shirt and like Jane Foster Thor,
and then Odin Suncor. And, and one of the funny things,
there's actually a theory floating around out there.
Now I'm not the one who came up with this theory, right? This is not my theory.
I want to get that kind of clear right off the bat. So people are just like,
I heard that from Rob, he's the one that made it up. That's not true.
I actually saw this theory kind of circulating around on the internet and a fan
actually gave it to me on Twitter. But it's, it's a,
it's a cool little equivalent tidbit here. Right?
So one of the questions people have asked is that if in Thor four,
we're going to have Chris Hemsworth Thor,
and then we're also going to have like Natalie Portman's, Jane Foster Thor, uh,
are they both gonna be running around at the same time?
Are we going to have like two Thor's in those, in that movie?
And I think the answer to that question is no,
we're not going to have two Thor's. I think we're going to have three. Uh,
this is going to be the crazy thing about right.
So like three Thor's and Thor four,
I think it's going to be kind of kind of bonkers. Uh, so here's the deal.
The story's based on Gore, the God, which,
or at least he's going to be the villain now as always with the Marvel cinematic
universe, never expect a direct adaptation of a comic quite,
which is to say basically the comic book being filmed shot for shot.
And then given, given to us in the, as,
as a movie going audience that never happens, right?
It's usually just the general idea of the story and then reworked for moving
forward, which usually makes sense because for the most part,
you can't really get away with the kind of things and movies that you can get
away with comics because you're working with real life actors,
you have a screenplay,
you got to make sure it stays under a certain amount of time.
There's a lot of variables that go into making a film, but in the original God,
what's your story.
But what you basically have there at least towards the end was three generations
of four all facing off against score. Now in the comic,
it was Thor from three different timelines, right?
So for when he was younger Thor in the modern era and thought in the future, um,
and the movie, I think it's going to be a little different, right?
I think we're going to get Jane Foster Thor in the future because somewhere
along the line between now and then Odin's son either loses the ability to lift
his hammer, or he passes it on to Jane Foster because like, Oh,
like somebody has got to run Asgard. And so, you know,
Thor's basically like I'm going to be the one to run the show here, Jane Foster,
you keep an eye on earth. And then he basically passes the mantle off to her.
Um, it could be that he loses the ability to wield his hammer, right?
He's no longer worthy of it, which is what happened in the comics. Right.
He lost his worthiness and was just kind of there, right?
Like you lose a storm breaker or whatever the case is,
maybe mule near comes back and he's not worthy of wielding it.
But whatever happens to be the case,
Jane Foster will be the one to take up the mantle.
So I wouldn't be surprised if you see Natalie Portman as Thor. Uh,
but she's older, right? She's maybe like 20 years older, 30 years older,
something like that. And then that kind of leaves the question.
What's the younger version of Thor that we're going to see.
And this is when things get interesting.
I think we're going to see beta Ray bill.
And a lot of people ask that what a lot of people are like, you know,
who would the younger four be in this situation?
And I think it would be beta Ray bill. I think we might end up getting him now.
The question is how and why, and that's the answer I don't really have,
but I don't have the answer to the question. How would we get beta Ray bill?
Or why would we get beta Ray bill?
Because the only thing we've seen about his character is he was one of the
champions on Sakaar right? And Thor three,
he was one of the former champions who was defeated at some point along at some
point along the line. And we never really found out when,
but I think it'd be cool to find out that he was defeated by the incredible
Hulk, right? When, when hope first showed up on Sakaar,
he defeated beta Ray bill and became the new champion. That would be awesome.
Right. But, um, but there's, there's,
there's nothing to really indicate that like beta Ray bill does in any form or
fashion have any dealings with any of the superheroes or any of the earth based,
uh,
based characters or anything and comics that would make a lot more sense because
when, when betray bill first showed up, when Walt Simonson was writing Thor,
that beta Ray bill was kind of an accidental discovery, right?
The beta Ray bill was kind of like this cyborg based protector of his people who
were leaving their planet because it was destroyed by Cerner.
And this led to Thor,
basically intervening at the request of Nick fury to find out what this great,
huge caravan of space-faring vehicles was doing.
And it led to a fight between thorn beta Ray bill,
and then ultimately a kind of tournament of sorts. Right. But, you know,
there was kind of instituted by Odin to determine who could wield mule near.
And, uh, when,
when beta Ray bill initially defeated Thor and picked up his hammer,
that's what led to the whole tournament and ultimately Odin, you know, uh,
beta Ray bill,
I think lost and Odin ended up giving him his own hammer called a storm breaker,
right? That's the original storm breaker hammer and one comics, uh,
things that you guys can tell have changed a lot in the MCU in comparison to the
conics. Uh, so because of that, there's,
there's really no telling how this could work. Um,
I think it'd be cool if we got beta Ray bill,
but I think that most likely what you'll see is just a younger version of Odin's
son. And I think that makes the most sense, right? A younger version of Thor,
uh,
who in his younger days was brash headstrong wouldn't really listen to reason.
And I think it'd be a great compliment to, you know,
in all honesty to kind of have this younger version of Thor,
who's trying to be tamed by his modern age self and to kind of see how far his,
how much his character has changed. You know,
since the time before he was banished from Asgard on earth and like how much
he's learned since he's been on earth, fighting alongside humans, you know,
during the events of infinity war, Avengers, end game, that kind of a thing. Um,
so there's, there's a lot of really cool storytelling that could be done there,
but for the long and short of this, in terms of how Jane Foster fits in,
I think that's what we're going to get. The real question to ask here is,
are we going to get that future version of low-key that killed the world, right?
Because those guys don't know. And, and the, and that story, right.
And Gore the God butcher, there's a point where it kind of ties into that story,
but not directly, it was actually during the events of journey and the mystery.
I think the comics that were being published at the time,
but there's one point where future low-key actually kills everything on earth.
Like all the superheroes, all the supervillains, all of humanity.
He literally wipes out the world, right? It's just this dead empty husk.
And a Thor is just kind of sitting in Asgard with all the Asgardians being dead
and he's just kind of the King of nothing. Right.
And then eventually Galactus shows up on earth trying to consume it.
And it leads to a great big fight between like old King Thor and Galactus,
which is super cool. I doubt we'll see Galactus and that, but, um, but you know,
suffice it to say in, in this whole thing,
I haven't said that phrase in a while, suffice it to say suffice it to say in,
in the midst of all this Thor for, I think it's going to be a really,
really fun and entertaining film. Uh, Gordon, God is an amazing villain.
He's captivating, he's riveting. Ah, he's wildly fascinating.
I would say he's probably the most interesting Thor villain that was ever
created in Marvel comics. Uh, so hats off to, to Jason,
Aaron for the invention of that character. But, uh, at this point, you know,
it's really too early to tell,
I just really too early to know exactly what the plot is going to be. Uh,
but you know, as we get closer to the release of the film,
we'll see like bits of news dropping and some spoiler leaks and,
and different things like that.
And we'll get a better indication of what the movie is going to look like.
But I wouldn't be surprised if the Jane Foster character in the Thor for film
is just a future version of Thor who wheels the hammer after,
for whatever reason, Odin's son ends up losing,
it ends up losing the ability to do so,
whether he chooses to give it up or he has to,
because he loses the ability to be worthy because we have to believe that
Mueller is going to come back at some point, right? It'll be remade.
It'll be reformed something along those lines. It's going to be gone forever.
Right. It's Thor's signature weapon. You know,
it's the one thing he's best known for is like the square looking hammer that he
just beat people up with. Right. So, um, either way,
I think it's going to be awesome. I'm very, very excited for it.
But I want to know your all's thoughts, what I want to hear your all's thoughts.
So post them down in the comment section, what do you think of this theory?
Right. Do you think it's a good one? Do you think it's a bad one?
Can you think of one better?
I'm really excited to see what kind of responses you guys have.
So with that being said, guys, we're going to read this video to an end.
If you are new here to come and explain and make sure you guys are the sub
button to become part of the rod core. If you guys enjoyed this video,
make sure you drop a light and I will catch you all later.
Oh, you said peace.
I will catch you all later.
[Inaudible].